[Music]
Daniel John John's quarterback a rookie
last year led the league in fumbles
that's not you want to lead the league
in good things not bad things fumbles
newsflash not a good thing interceptions
tied for 11th with 12
he spoke with reporters in virtual
fashion on Wednesday and he spoke about
his efforts to improve ball security in
2020 here yes I think the biggest thing
is ball security and and you know
particularly in the pocket protecting
the ball so you know I think that's a
that's a fundamental skill at the
quarterback position that's something
that's you know crucial but but also to
me a fairly simple thick and that it's a
mindfulness a certain you know being
intentional to securing the ball to
having two hands on it to you know when
you're moving when you're having to
adjust in the pocket you're you're
maintaining that security so I'm just
trying to try and emphasize that doing
different drills and making sure that
I'm you know always cognizant of that
and being very intentional and in that
you know Chris anytime I think of a
giant and ball security I think at Tiki
Barber when Tom Coughlin taught him how
to hold the ball high and tight and how
it cured his chronic fumbling issues
obviously that's not something a
quarterback can do
it's hard to throw the ball quickly if
you're cradling the ball a little bit
what can you do it's the disconnect
between all the stuff that a guy can say
you're out there in the fray you're
being chased around by very large men
with hostile intentions it's not like
you can say oh I got to remember to
protect the ball it's chaos at that
point what can you really do to improve
your ball security in the pocket to
avoid fumbling it when you get hit by
one of these guys who is larger and
stronger and faster than you well what
you know one hey first the game will
slow down for Daniel Jones right we hear
that phrase all the time and what I mean
by that is you know Daniel Jones first
off the fumbling and we talked about
this the other day a little bit it's not
hey listen it's not a good thing don't
get me wrong but it's not something I
oh man Daniel Jones has a problem and
I'm worried he'll never be able to fix
this no look at some of these plays
really when you look at a lot of his
fumbles you're gonna go man he's just so
fearless in the pocket and he just
stands in there looking up people around
him and he just doesn't care to where
he'll have a better feel for the offense
and the speed of the game and the [ __ ]
in his head in year two now as far as
the drills are concerned Mike there's
definitely things you can do and you're
right it's hard to emulate you know six
six three hundred and twenty pound guys
trying to rip your head off but you know
the thing you do hey there's drop back
shuffle through cones make sure you got
two hands on the ball drop back move
around the pocket and you'd like to have
somebody there
leather quarterbacks quarterback coach
you know have the little blocking
dummies and you hit at the quarterbacks
wrists and arms as he's sitting in the
pocket and going through Reed's just so
he's always feeling it and maybe moving
it and dipping it a little bit just to
keep it out of the way of hands reach
now it's hard to do in practice right
now and I don't know if Daniel Jones I
don't think he's married if he's got a
girlfriend at home that might be
something I would ask her to do listen I
asked my wife to do that type of stuff
all the time especially when I was
recovering from my spleen ectomy so but
there is things you could do and of
course talking about it and and showing
old footage of it and all those things
are also a big part of the learning
process
yeah and III also think that that it
it's just part of the overall
understanding of how you and your body
your arms the football how all of that
fits with what's going on around you and
it's just definitely I think
acceleration of the clock like when we
see Chandler Jones hit Daniel Jones as
he's trying to get rid of the football
well you got to make your decision a
little fast you have to anticipate great
collapsing around you so you got to get
rid of the ball before you're in your
motion I mean it's hard to fault a guy
for having bad ball security when he's
in his throwing motion and his arm gets
hit because the balls is exposed as its
ever gonna be
you just got to get rid of it fast you
have to anticipate
and you got to make your decision and
you have to move it faster and as you
say when the game slows down it's going
to be easier for him to realize when
that clock expires it doesn't expire
when they cave in the side of your knee
and tear your ACL it expires when
they're close enough to hit your arm and
knock the ball out yeah that's exactly
right and you know again you don't want
to be the the Statute of Liberty at the
pocket either you know and that's one
thing because Daniel Jones is so smart
and he's such an accurate thrower of the
football I mean he really is I mean he
is pinpoint you can throw lasers the
perfect spy Rose you know he wants to
rely on that strength of his game and I
understand that but he's a very good
athlete too and he is capable we saw him
last year ripping off 20 and 25 yard
type runs to where hey use that to your
advantage too and there's a skill set
you know Mike once you learn to play
position and football a little bit as
great as Tom Brady is in the pocket you
know he's got a great way of being able
to one still look down the field like an
Aaron Rodgers but yet still feel the
pass rush and there's there's that's
part of soul in the game down to you're
sitting in the pocket and you're looking
down but every now and then you just
kind of give a quick peek around him
wait am i okay is somebody gonna hit me
make me fumble okay let me get my eyes
back up you know the really good ones
can kind of see both at the same time
and I think Daniel Jones is gonna have
those capabilities but I like the fact
that he was so tough in the pocket last
year I think it's a positive I really do
he's not a guy that seeing ghosts are
scared or anything like that I think
this is a fixable problem well and it's
a problem that definitely needs to be
fixed Chris to put it in perspective 18
fumbles by Daniel Jones was the most
forest season by a quarterback since
2002 my guess is it probably was Dante
Culpepper who was a notorious bumbler
that's right he was a giant his hands
were tiny but Jones had his 18 fumbles
in 12 games not 16 games that's one and
a half fumbles per game and 11 of the 12
fumbles were lost you're not gonna win
many games if your quarterback is
turning the ball
over one and a half times per game just
by putting it on the ground Chris no
you're not but you know let's not forget
that offensive line was nothing to write
home about right you know there's some
new receivers out there and Golden Tate
sterling Shepard was hurt a little bit
you know Darius Layton might have been
the best best receiver they had on the
team last year you know you had no
running game to rely on they put a lot
on Daniel Jones's shoulders and the 12
games he had a play last year you know
III think I've made fun of it the other
day I mean as a rookie from his first
start down in Tampa they were basically
like hey Daniel we can't run the ball
that great we can't pass protect that
great we're gonna need you to throw the
ball 40 times and throw three touchdowns
to win a football game and that's a lot
to ask of a rookie but but he had some
moments last year where you know you'd
be crazy not to sit there and go man
this guy's got something special about
him and I I think he's a big reason why
you know josh mcdaniels wanted the
Giants job and there was a mother bunch
of coaches that were you know clamoring
to get it because I think they saw the
potential in Daniel Jones by the way
Pete Demmel itis informs me that
Culpepper had 23 fumbles in 2002 and car
then a rookie with the Houston Texans
had 21 but they presumably played more
than 12 games that you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports